3 mois d'enquête avant que Jonathan
Daval ne passe aux aveux sous la
pression d'éléments
accablants c'est d'abord un témoignage
déterminant qui a orienté les enquêteurs
celui d'un des voisins du couple il
affirme avoir entendu une voiture
quitter le domicile des Daval à 1h30 du
matin la nuit précédant la disparition
d'Alexia le véhicule de fonction a été
expertisé par les enquêteurs et
l'analyse de composant électronique est
formel la voiture a bien bougé cette
nuit-là jusqu'à aujourd'hui pourtant la
version de Jonathan Daval était tout
autre lui a toujours expliqué qu'Alexia
était parti courir à 9h du matin il
avait lui-même appelé les gendarme pour
signaler sa
disparition 48 he plus tard le corps
d'Alexia partiellement brûlé sera
retrouvé dans un
bois sur les lieux les enquêteurs
découvrent d'autres indices matériel
des traces de pneus qui correspondent à
la voiture de Jonathan Daval mais aussi
des morceaux de tissu de draps qui
appartenaient au couple enfin desar
avait été constaté sur les bras de son
époux nous nous sommes disputés avait
alors expliquer Jonathan Daval au
gendarmes au début de l'enquête à
l'époque aucun élément matériel ne
permettait de contredire cette
[Musique]
version